[Musique]
salut à tous vous l'avez certainement
remarqué le dernier grand combat des
féministes en ce moment est de vouloir
féminiser la grammaire pour faire
avancer l'égalité hommes femmes
alors en fait cette lubie n'est pas
nouvelle puisque l'écriture inclusive
existe à l'extrême gauche depuis début
des années 2000 et dans mon jeune temps
il y avait plein de façons de torture
l'orthographe mettre des majuscules
d'étirer ou encore des points mais
aujourd'hui ces paysages se répand en or
de ces milieux et au passage il faut
souligner que cette revendication à la
base n'est pas une revendication
féministe le féminisme étant traversé
par plein de courant mais spécifiquement
féministes radicales qui lui même ne
représente pas l'intégralité du
féminisme d'extrême gauche
c'est donc à la base une revendication
extrêmement spécifique à un milieu donné
aujourd'hui on va donc se pencher sur
cette revendication d'écriture inclusive
et démonter les arguments et théories
qui la sous tendent il y a deux
arguments majeurs d'avancé le premier
est que le langage porterait une vision
du monde et définirait notre façon de
penser
c'est un argument on retrouve
aujourd'hui jusque dans les
recommandations officielles ainsi une
autorité dépendante de l'état le haut
conseil à l'égalité entre les hommes et
les femmes déclare dans son guide
pratique pour une communication publique
sans stéréotype de sexe la langue
reflète la société et sa façon de penser
le monde
ainsi l'ong qui rend les femmes
invisibles et la marque d'une société où
elle joue un rôle second c'est bien
parce que le langage et politique que la
langue française a été infléchie
délibérément vers le masculin durant
plusieurs siècles par les groupes qui
s'opposaient l'égalité des sexes
l'argument part d'un constat historique
la règle du masculin générique c'est à
dire qu'il sous-entend le masculin et le
féminin remonte en france au xviie
siècle elle a été imaginée par claude
favre de beaux glace à la demande du roi
qui voulaient fixer le français cette
règle a effectivement une origine
sexistes puisque favre est parti du
principe que le plus noble le masculin
était censé de l'emporter
un autre argument complémentaires qui
revient souvent et qui est sous-entendu
par le haut conseil est qu écrire au
masculin briderait l'imaginaire et donc
contribuerait à la répartition des rôles
hommes femmes
quand on parle de 1 médecin on empêche
les petites filles de se lancer elle
aussi médecin quand on dit
systématiquement une infirmière pareil
on exclut les garçons de ce métier si le
français véhicule le sexisme à cause de
sa grammaire alors il est intéressant de
se pencher sur les rapports hommes
femmes dans des pays non francophones
qui ont donc d'autres règles de
grammaire pour voir si la langue
véhicule réellement le sexisme ou s'il
s'agit d'une erreur d'interprétation lié
à la structure particulière de notre
langue allons d'abord en afrique et
prenons le groupe d langue peule dont
vous parlez dans une vingtaine de pays
de l'ouest africain comme le sénégal le
mali le cameroun etc en peul il existe
un terme pour chaque sexe physique qui
dérivent d'un terme générique non sexuée
on a donc une langue parfaitement
égalitaire les mots n'aime pas dehors et
on peut exprimer le caractère mâle
femelle neutre à l'envié
l'autre grand groupe de langues
africaines le ventoux qui est parlée en
afrique sub tropicales marche à peu près
par les théoriquement on a là un
continent où les langues ne sont pas
vecteur de sexisme correspondent à ce
que veulent les féministes radicales et
vont même plus loin puisqu'il est un
genre neutre
on ne pourra pas dire qu'on brider
l'imagination des petits enfants
africains et pourtant la situation des
femmes africaines n'est guère enviable
le mariage forcé et l'excision sont des
pratiques qui perdurent toujours dans de
nombreux pays et ce n'est pas la
modification du langage qui les fait
reculer actuellement mais l'influencé
des idées occidentales lassés la théorie
de la langue comme vecteur de liberté ou
d'oppression qui en prend un coup
maintenant revenons en europe et faisant
le chemin inverse partons du politique
depuis le début des années 2000
plusieurs pays ou ont eu des femmes
comme dirigeant l'angleterre l'allemagne
la pologne la croatie la finlande et
l'estonie
alors est-ce que les langues de ces pays
ont des particularités
l'allemand a trois genres masculin
féminin est neutre tout comme le croate
et le polonais l'anglais le finnois et
l'estonien eux n'ont pas de genre
en fait en europe vous avez deux types
de langues différentes les langues avec
de genre masculin et féminin
typiquement ce sont les langues latines
et à côté vous avez les langues slaves
et germaniques qui ont plutôt trois
genres ou alors qu'ils n'en ont aucun
tout cela peut donner l'impression que
ces dernières sont plus égalitaire que
les langues latines et c'est vrai qu'en
europe les femmes dirigeantes issus de
pays de langue germanique ou slaves
donc on pourrait dire qu'il ya quand
même un lien entre la langue est
politique mais en amérique latine
cristina kirchner michelle bachelet et
dilma rousseff a récemment dirigé leur
pays de langue espagnole et portugaise
et il faut ajouter qu'en europe les
femmes dirigeantes est plutôt issus des
rangs conservateurs
comme quoi ce n'est ni une question de
structure linguistique d'une question de
couleur politique
la place des femmes dans la société n'a
donc rien à voir avec l'existant ce
genre grammatico la généralisation tiré
de l'exemple français et donc abusive et
le fondement idéologique sur lesquels
reposent l'écriture inclusive est faux
cela s'explique par le fait que derrière
l'argument historique et linguistique
qui est très partielle et partiale comme
on l'a vu se cache en fait des
idéologies bien particulière le
structuralisme et le post structuralisme
de philosophie qui ont été très en vogue
dans les années 60 et 70
à gauche et qui reste aujourd'hui encore
très prégnant dans le féminisme radical
le structuralisme part du principe qu'il
existe des entités les structures qui
nous guide inconsciemment dans nos actes
quotidiens nous faisons répétées des
schémas préétablis dans les différents
domaines de nourri ces structures ne
sont pas simplement des valeurs ou des
schémas que l'on nous aurait enseigné
dans l'enfance mais aurait une forme
d'existence propre hors de la pensée et
l'histoire humaine
c'est un peu comme la psychanalyse qui
pour l influence du sexe partout
d'ailleurs les structuralistes était
aussi souvent intéressés par la
psychanalyse résultat c'est une
philosophie qui vaut une symbolique
partout
de plus tous les domaines de nos vies
seraient connectés et la structure est
un tout cohérent si bien que les
domination sexuelle économiques
culturels s'emboîtent les unes dans les
autres et se renforcerait mutuellement
et dans cette optique le langage est un
vecteur important de domination
roland barthes un philosophe
structuraliste allant même jusqu'à dire
que le langage est fasciste
alors c'est une philosophie relativement
fumeuses et assez abstraite mais voici
un exemple
appliqué au domaine des arts le
structuralisme revient à dire que les
notes de musique puis contribuer à
générer
racisme car une blanche vaut deux noires
et donc fatalement remplacer ses
couleurs par des formes géométriques par
exemple contribuerait à réduire le
racisme voilà pour le structuralisme
quant au post structuralisme lieu de
s'intéresser à l'analyse de la structure
il s'intéresse à comment la briser pour
émanciper et comme la structure
homogénéise vous fait couler dans des
moules le post structuralisme part du
principe qu'il faut visibiliser les
éléments qui contribuent à
l'hétérogénéité doux concrètement ces
dernières années la multiplication des
sigles sur les questions lgbt
plus on les multiplie plus on attaque
l'hégémonie de la structure de ce qu'ils
appellent les terreaux patriarcat si ce
genre maintenant revenons à notre
écriture inclusive dans leur lecture
féministe ces théories pose donc comme
principe qu'il y aurait un lien logique
et de subordination entre les
conventions d'écriture et les rapports
sociaux
si le féminin est invisible à l'écrit il
le sera aussi dans l'espace social
économique et culturel et inversement
s'il est visible à l'écrit il le sera
partout et il découle de ce lien magique
entre les différentes sphères que lutter
contre le sexisme dans l'une d'elles se
répercute dans les autres lutter pour
l'écriture inclusive c'est aussi lutter
pour l'égalité salariale ou politique à
peu de frais et si on n'est pas
structuraliste une voie où est l'erreur
elle met une égalité entre genre
grammatical et genre sémantique c'est à
dire le sexe alors que l'en est une
convention qui est l'autre une réalité
biologique et que les deux ne sont pas
liés par exemple on d une mangouste et
un phacochère est pourtant quasiment sûr
qu'il existe des mangoustes mal et des
phacochères fumel et le gros problème
dans la sphère c'est qu'après avoir
refusé pendant 15 ans au sein de la
gauche radicale
on nous impose aujourd'hui tous membres
sans aucun débat via des recommandations
officielles et des manuels scolaires des
pratiques liées à une idéologie
aberrante le pire avec ces polémiques
sur l'écriture inclusive c'est qu'on
risque par contrecoup de provoquer un
rejet des thèmes bien l'égalité hommes
femmes
et pourtant à côté de certaines inepties
you structuralisme et bien par exemple
où tout n'est pas à jeter dans le vide
du haut conseil pour l'égalité hommes
femmes
bref j'espère que maintenant on
comprenait mieux les tenants et les
aboutissants du débat lié à l'écriture
inclusive dans une prochaine vidéo qu'on
verra comment cette idéologie partie
d'un tout petit milieu a pu arriver
jusqu'aux institutions sans aucun débat
ni sela jeudi portez vous bien et à la
prochaine
[Musique]